digamos que tengo 40 años
estoy casada
tengo dos hijos
y soy quien lleva los ingresos
principales de la casa
entonces yo traigo los ingresos
principales también tenemos una hipoteca
hipoteca
y también yo espero que mis hijos vayan
a la universidad así que voy a tener que
pagar su colegiatura de la universidad y
también quiero asegurarme de que mi
esposo en caso de que algo me ocurra
pueda retirarse ya que a lo mejor mi
pareja no puede tener todos los ingresos
que yo tengo o en caso de que él sí lo
pueda hacer de todas maneras va a tener
que hacerse cargo de los hijos si es que
algo me ocurriera a mí y debido a todas
estas cosas pues yo quiero asegurarme de
que cada una de estas pueda pagarse en
la eventualidad de que yo fallezca y por
eso quiero contratar un seguro de vida
un seguro de vida
seguro de vida y yo creo que la mayoría
de nosotros comprendemos la idea general
acerca de los seguros de vida aquí se
paga una cantidad cada cierto tiempo y
en el evento de fallecimiento los
familiares de quien fallece que estén
como beneficiarios de este seguro de
vida o en el testamento esas personas
son las que van a recibir el pago de
este seguro de vida pero los seguros de
vida no son tan sencillos hay dos
versiones de los seguros de vida una de
ellas es bastante sencilla la otra no lo
es tanto una de ellas es el seguro de
vida por periodo
de vida
por periodo periodo y el otro es seguro
de vida completo
seguro de vida
completo
y ahorita voy a hablar del seguro de
vida por periodo que es bastante más
simple digamos que yo voy con mi agente
de seguros y mi agente me dice si tú
pagas una prima de 500 dólares por
ejemplo esa palabra prima significa
literalmente la cantidad que yo voy a
pagar cada año si yo pago una prima cada
año de 500 dólares durante 10 años aquí
el periodo es de 10 años
si yo falleciera en algún momento
durante estos 10 años el seguro me
pagaría o le daría a mis beneficiarios
la cantidad de
tienen dos mil dólares los beneficiarios
como lo indica su nombre son las
personas que se van a beneficiar cuando
se cumpla este seguro en el en el evento
de mi fallecimiento así que durante los
siguientes diez años yo voy a estar
pagando 500 dólares por año y si yo
llegara a fallecer durante estos diez
años mis beneficiarios recibirán 500 mil
dólares y la razón por la que esto
funciona para las compañías de seguros
es que si ellas ven que uno está sano
uno no fuma ni bebe es difícil que uno
muera durante los siguientes diez años
así que si esto lo promedia entre miles
de personas pues van a poder pagar esto
sin que les cueste nada sin duda algunos
de ellos fallece dan pero por los que
vivan van a recibir la prima anual de
500 dólares y eso va a superar con
creces esta cantidad de los 500 mil
dólares del seguro que se tienen que dar
en el caso del fallecimiento de una
persona asegurada y la razón por la que
esto se llama seguro de vida por periodo
es que una vez que terminan estos diez
años una vez que terminen estos diez
años hay que sacar una nueva póliza de
seguro si uno sigue vivo después de
estos diez años pues no ocurre nada todo
sigue normal solo que el dinero que ya
pague durante estos diez años pues no lo
voy a recuperar este dinero se lo quedó
la compañía de seguros y esto no está
tan mal si uno tiene 40 años y la póliza
es por 10 años ya que para una persona
de 40 50 años seguramente cae en la edad
en que los hijos comienzan ir a la
universidad da más tiempo para ahorrar
más dinero para el retiro y también más
tiempo para pagar la hipoteca y también
ahorrar un poco más para el pago de la
universidad así que aún no puede decir
bueno este periodo de diez años es
perfecto para mí si uno que tiene
cuarenta años piensa que necesita más
tiempo para ahorrar para pagar la
hipoteca y ahorrar para la universidad y
para el retiro entonces aquí se puede
tener una póliza a veinte años
y si nuestro periodo es de 20 años
seguramente nuestra prima va a ser mayor
y la razón por la que la prima aumenta
es porque durante estos 20 años aumenta
la probabilidad de que yo pudiera
fallecer si tomamos en cuenta que en
este caso era de 40 a 50 años y en este
caso es de 40 a 60 años así que la
compañía de seguros tomar en cuenta
estas probabilidades y aumentará la
prima correspondiente en consecuencia
pero de cualquier manera en que lo
veamos en este seguro de vida por
periodo vamos a pagar una cantidad fija
anual durante el periodo que contratemos
el seguro si uno fallece durante este
periodo entonces la familia o
beneficiarios recibirán esta cantidad de
asegurada si uno no fallece pues la
póliza va a expirar y no pasa nada
tendrá que contratarse a otra póliza de
seguro por otro periodo y quizá para el
momento en el que ustedes alcancen los
70 años ya va a ser bastante difícil
contratar una póliza de seguro por
periodo ya que a los 70 años ya hay una
alta probabilidad de fallecer y esto
a la compañía de seguros de vida ya no
le convendría así que el seguro de vida
por periodo es algo muy bueno cuando uno
tiene cierta edad es de mediana edad y
quiere asegurarse de que la familia
tenga el dinero suficiente para
sobrellevar estos pagos particulares en
caso de que algo le suceda al asegurado
así pues en caso de fallecimiento la
familia o los beneficiarios pueden usar
esta cantidad para hacer estos pagos o
cubrir esas obligaciones y de hecho esto
es algo que yo tengo contratado ya que
actualmente yo tengo 40 años tengo una
hipoteca tengo un hijo pequeño y quiero
asegurarme de que cualquier cosa que me
pueda ocurrir mi familia no quede
desamparada en este caso creo que mi
seguro de vida es por 20 años así que si
algo me sucede durante estos 20 años mi
familia va a tener lo suficiente para
poder hacerse cargo de esto sin tener
que padecer privaciones el otro tipo de
seguro es el seguro de vida completo el
motivo de estas pólizas de seguro de
vida completas viene de la noción de que
muchas personas
no les gusta la idea de que se pagan
dinero en un seguro de vida por periodo
cada año durante los años que dure la
póliza pero si uno no fallece lo que
francamente es algo bueno pero si uno no
fallece pues todo ese dinero se lo quedó
la compañía de seguros y ya no se
recibió nada de vuelta no se ahorro no
nos va a ser de beneficio para la
persona asegurada y otro problema es que
este seguro de vida por periodo pues
sólo es válido durante ese periodo diez
años veinte años por el tiempo que esté
establecida y algunas personas dicen
saben que yo quiero mantener esta prima
fija durante toda mi vida y cuando yo
fallezca y como sabemos a todos nos va a
tocar algún día fallecer cuando el
asegurado fallezca va a haber un
beneficio así que a lo mejor tengo
ahorita 45 años y dentro de 40 años que
yo siga pagando esta prima cuando yo
fallezca a los 85 años pues mi familia
de todas maneras va a recibir un
beneficio de esto así que este seguro de
vida completo pues es una respuesta
para estas inquietudes sin embargo las
compañías de seguro de vida pues no son
tontas esas compañías analizan con
cuidado todas las probabilidades para
asegurarse de que ellos no pierdan así
que lo que ocurre con los seguros de
vida completos es que se hace un cargo
mayor por la prima uno obtiene lo que se
tiene en este seguro de vida y además se
tiene una parte de ahorros pero cobran
bastante por ello para que les resulte
un buen negocio aquí voy a poner un
ejemplo pero voy a inventar las
cantidades les recomiendo que si están
interesados en adquirir algún tipo de
seguro hablen con algún agente algún
especialista en el tema para que los
oriente de mejor manera en este caso
nuestra prima será suponiendo que vamos
a recibir o que los beneficiaros van a
recibir esta misma cantidad la prima va
a ser bastante mayor que ésta en este
caso en lugar de 500 dólares podría ser
de 5 mil 2
anuales y aquí el periodo es toda la
vida
periodo que de hecho ni debería
describir esto de periodo porque pues no
existe es implícito en el nombre por eso
es completo así que uno va a estar
pagando esta prima hasta que uno
fallezcan y entonces es cuando la
familia va a recibir el pago del seguro
en caso de fallecimiento
fallecimiento
los beneficiarios recibirán los 500 mil
dólares y a lo mejor ustedes pueden
decir pues esto es un abuso como voy a
pagar más por prima y recibir al final
la misma cantidad y hay un par de cosas
a considerar que hacen que esto no sea
realmente tan abusivo aunque de todas
maneras eso tiende a ser una opción
quizás no tan inteligente como el seguro
de vida por periodo pero aquí lo que
sucede es que siempre y cuando nosotros
sigamos pagando la prima de este seguro
se garantiza que esta cantidad se va a
recibir y es seguro que todos vamos a
morir algún día a menos que ustedes
sepan algo que yo no conozco así que en
el seguro de vida por periodo una vez
que uno alcanza cierta edad de unos 60 a
70 años las compañías de seguro nos van
a cobrar mucho más cantidad de prima que
si estuviéramos más jóvenes ya que hay
una mayor probabilidad de que en ese
rango de edades uno pueda fallecer en
cambio en el seguro de vida completo uno
paga
a la misma prima aunque esta cara pero
es la misma cantidad que se va a pagar
durante toda la vida así que bueno si
uno está entre los 30 o 40 años sin duda
esta prima va a ser mucho más cara que
ésta pero quizás cuando uno llegue a los
70 80 años uno seguirá pagando esto en
este seguro en cambio en el otro seguro
de vida por periodo si uno lo contrata a
esa edad entre 70 y 80 años de entrada
puede que ni uno lo consiga no lo
aprueben y si lo aprueban la prima sería
enorme tremendamente cara mucho más cara
que ésta podría ser de seis mil dólares
al año o de diez mil dólares y en ese
punto en la vida pues esto es mucho más
barato otro aspecto es que en este caso
el seguro de vida una parte de este
dinero se va a destinar a asegurar su
vida y otra parte se va a destinar a
efectivos
efectivo y este efectivo va a recibir
intereses durante el tiempo no toda la
prima va a este efectivo una parte va a
este efectivo solo una parte lo hace
seguramente los primeros años en los que
se pague esta prima toda esta cantidad
irá hacia la compañía de seguros pero
después cada año en una fracción de esta
prima irá a una cuenta de ahorros dentro
de la compañía de seguros así que vamos
a ponerle aquí este efectivo es un
ahorro una cuenta de ahorros y puede
generar intereses puede generar
intereses siempre que se mantenga en
esta compañía del seguro de vida así que
alguien que quiera venderles ese tipo de
seguro les va a decir oye esa es una muy
buena opción pagas una prima fija se
garantiza que esta prima va a quedar
fija durante toda tu vida tu familia
eventualmente recibirá esta cantidad
garantizada claro siempre y cuando se
siga pagando la prima puntualmente cada
año y además te tenemos una cuenta de
ahorros
y uno puede en cierto momento decir oye
todos estos elementos ya no los tiene
que cubrir mi familia y ya no quiero
pagar este seguro de vida quizás ya
tenemos 65 años ya nuestros hijos
salieron de la universidad ya pagamos
nuestra hipoteca y se decide que pues ya
no es necesario estar haciendo este pago
anual así que esto ya no se recibiría
pero si tendríamos acceso a esta cuenta
de ahorros aunque aquí hay un detalle
esto parece muy bueno demasiado bueno
para ser verdad ya que es un seguro de
vida es una cuenta de ahorros pero algo
que quizás no nos digan desde el
principio es que cobran comisiones muy
grandes en esta cuenta así que si su
objetivo era ahorrar ese dinero pues
mejor hubieran tomado este dinero
directamente al banco y no invertirlo en
este seguro de vida con cuenta de
ahorros hubiera sido mejor pagar ese
seguro de vida por cierto periodo sin
estas primas tan caras y ahorrar lo
demás podrían haber tomado esta opción y
la diferencia de las primas que bueno
en que yo inventé estos números pero si
existiera este caso pago mi prima de 500
dólares y los 4500 dólares restantes
pues los invierto en una cuenta de
ahorros en el banco no en una compañía
de seguros así que esta diferencia de
los 4500 dólares la pude invertir porque
acuérdense que esto es anual la puedo
ahorrar
y la puedo invertir
etcétera así que durante este periodo
del seguro de vida pues podríamos haber
ahorrado una cantidad bastante
interesante y recibir intereses de todo
esto ya que no se pagarían tantas
comisiones como en este caso y me acabo
de dar cuenta que no he respondido a una
pregunta que quizás ustedes tienen
ahorita en la mente ya habíamos
mencionado que si nosotros estamos con
este tipo de seguro vamos a pagar esta
prima fija durante toda nuestra vida y
en el evento del fallecimiento la
familia o beneficiarios tienen asegurado
que van a recibir esta cantidad los
500.000
pero si antes del fallecimiento nosotros
decimos que ya no vamos a necesitar este
seguro se puede dejar de pagar la prima
la familia no recibirá este beneficio en
el caso de fallecimiento pero sí se
podrá sacar lo que se tiene en esta
parte de la cuenta de ahorros con
efectivo claro lo que quede después de
que la compañía de seguros cobrará sus
cuotas pero la pregunta que quizás
tienen ustedes es bueno qué sucede con
esta parte de la cuenta de ahorros
cuando yo fallezca qué pasa aquí ya
sabemos que los beneficiarios van a
recibir esta cantidad ya que podemos
retirar este dinero antes de fallecer y
en el fallecimiento los beneficiarios
reciben esta cantidad pero qué pasa con
esta cuenta de ahorros y la respuesta
aquí es que no se recibe o se recupera
nada de esto podrían imaginar esto como
lo que respalda a esta cantidad del
seguro de vida
de esto es que si esta cantidad llegara
a ser mayor que la cantidad asegurada
puede ser esta cantidad se pierde como
podría darse este caso bueno a lo mejor
ustedes vivieron una cantidad de tiempo
inesperada a lo mejor vivieron 50 años
más así que durante estos 50 años
ustedes estuvieron pagando cinco mil
dólares cada uno de esos años esto se
invierte y se tiene un interés compuesto
que se va aumentando año con año en esta
cuenta de ahorros y quizá al final en
esta cuenta de ahorros se llegó a tener
o se alcanzó a tener 600 mil dólares y a
pesar de esto en el caso del
fallecimiento la familia solo va a
recibir esta cantidad nada más y a lo
mejor esto les hace pensar que si esta
cantidad de ahorros es mayor que la
cantidad de asegurada pues lo mejor es
dejar de pagar la prima y cobrar o sacar
lo que hay en esta cuenta de ahorros y
dársela a la familia mientras uno
todavía está vivo en lugar de esperar a
fallecer ya que
es peor de dos maneras primero uno ya
falleció y segundo van a recibir una
cantidad menor que si se hubiera
ahorrado este dinero y se les hubiera
dado con todo e intereses así que
respondiendo la pregunta en el caso del
fallecimiento los beneficiarios no ven
ni un centavo de esta cuenta de ahorros
solo reciben esta cantidad asegurada